Chứ này nhìn bú tháng 1 năm 2020, các quan tỉnh sát điều tra công an tỉnh cầm mau cho biết đã hử tụi hủ an sít người sế ra tại sát cái đối vầm, cầm mau.
Không thủ là hủ ankit, sinh năm 2020, chú sát tinh thủy tình bính lòng, tạm chú ốc bà, sát cái đối vầm, đang làm thưi cho một chủ tổ cá ở đi phương.
Tại các quan điều tra, kịch khai nhận có quen biết với nạn như là cháu vê tìm mở cá, sinh năm 2020, hậu bà, hậu bẩy ở sớp phụ tân, cầm mau.
Chứ đó, kịch mở của an ká ba trong hành động, rồi sau đó lấy lý só trả tình tỉ hạnh tập lạnh nhân.
Lúc người sấu dựng em muốn tắm một năm 2020, an ká trẻ sế đập định để khu bật gần chú sửi bán nhân dân só phụ tân tỉnh nhận tình.
Sau khi trả lạnh tình, kịch tức tục dụi cá đi cùng về đoại tình một người tên khoa và hướn nếu lấy được tình sẽ cho cá muốn chự động.
Tình lời, cá đồng ý đi theo kịch.
Kịch trở nạn như đến đoạn đường vây tông vắng sok et lo một tụi át tâm, giá ca đôi vòng thì dừng sẽ lại,
tại đây kịch quay sẵn sẵn sẵn hải ca và bị nạn nhân chống cụ kết định,
sự các tỉ lại sự việc vưới ra đing, kịch lấy hụi khi mắt theo sách hải ca rồi đề tý tỉ thị xuống đồng tông của người dân.
Sau khi về an, kịch vết bỏ địa thải, mù sụ đồ đặc của nạn nhân dồi dưới khỏi hiện chương.